[Music]
as we find ourselves at the brink of
World War I maybe even over the brink
into World War I I find myself in London
which tomorrow will be the site of a
massive Pro Palestine protest this after
3 weeks or so following the uh largest
attack ever on the state of Israel which
killed over 1,000 people some estimates
up to 1500 people uh the Israeli
Palestine conflict not the only
potential outbreak of World War II we
also of course have the conflict in
Ukraine and some other conflicts around
the world and some other religious
persecutions and some other hot spots in
international diplomacy as it falls
apart so I decided to come to Canterbury
Cathedral to meet with Father Benedict
key who knows a thing or two about
religious persecution uh father key is
the founder of nazarene.org that is
nazaran with an S not with a z so it's
n
a.org father key I believe you've been
to Iraq nine times to support persecuted
Christians you have installed shrines to
persecuted Christians all around the
world at a time when people don't want
to talk about persecuted Christians or
really much religious persecution
whatsoever you're right and thank you
for having me my ministry as a priest
Catholic priest is full-time speaking
writing advocacy for p persecuted
Christians but also we have a very small
charity which tries to keep Christians
in their homelands by many micro
financing small family businesses so now
in Iraq Syria Lebanon and Egypt and soon
please God in Armenia we give them a
small amount of money they start a
business they stay in their own
countries that's a very practical and
positive thing to deal with yes what
you're talking about this massive crisis
Christianity is the most persecuted
religion in the world it's not
fashionable to say it but it is the most
persecuted Christ uh religion in the
world persecuted more than in the first
centuries of the of the church uh seems
to not be on the radar certainly not the
radar of mainstream media that's why I'm
so grateful to you and you raised as you
said in your introduction another place
which we'll talk about I'm sure Armenia
um but yes it's to to try and alert
Christians first and foremost to the
fact that their Brethren our Brothers
and Sisters in Christ are being
persecuted for their faith for being
Christians for no other reason the
Israelis have experienced this grotesque
attack for being Jews but we often say
and it's a phrase from the Middle East
first they come for the Saturday people
then they come for the Sunday people in
other words uh that's a kind of a point
of meeting between Christians and Jews
not a pleasant point of meeting but
that's one of the reasons why we believe
that we should be with our Jewish
Brethren uh it's not a mercenary thing
but but we're sharing in the suffering
uh and so it's a very tough time I can't
help but notice that the the people who
attacked the state of Israel are the
same people who have run the Christians
out of Iraq when I heard that you'd
visited Iraq nine times I thought has
father key visited Iraq more than the
number of Christians who are left in
Iraq at this point well that's a very
sad thing yes When The War The Invasion
in 2003 happened there were a million
and a half Christians in Iraq and and
again for an American audience sometimes
people say to me well when did we bring
the gospel to Iraq and sorry it's the
other way around Disciples of Jesus
brought the gospel to Iraq and they
brought the gospel to us so ancient
Christian communities uh but now from a
million and uh a million and a half in
2003 now in
2023 there's about 100 ,000 Christians
left in Iraq they've been driven out
first of course not just by ISIS by all
the persecution that happened before we
forget that persecution was going on
with Al-Qaeda and various other people
and then uh economic problems their
second class citizens uh the World
Wildlife Fund has a a list of danger
areas for for for Animals you know uh it
goes up up and down and the Christians
in Iraq would fit in the nearly extinct
category if they were animals which is
terrifying and frightening which is why
I feel a real passion that we we
Christians in the west must do whatever
we can for our persecuted Brethren but
of course in the mainstream liberal
media you'll hear hand ringing and
nashing of teeth over the extinction of
the Delta smelt in California but Nar a
mention of of Christians who are
persecuted in the Middle East and
elsewhere you know I mean we're talking
about the very real possibility of
genocide today uh and there's a genocide
that is currently happening and it's one
that has recurred at times throughout
history and that's in a conflict that
very few people have heard of if you
pulled a thousand people on the street
and said what do you know about the
negoro carabat conflict I think most
people would look at you like you had
three heads but this is the persecution
by aeran of Armenian Christians Armenia
the oldest Christian country in the
world and it's happening right now well
I'm grateful to you again because you
raised this on your Show recently it is
nobody's talking about it Armenia which
is technically a European country it's
in Europe but yes the oldest Christian
country in the world 301 before
Constantine was baptized they became
Christians the azanis who are a sort of
Greater turkey that's basically what
it's about uh seizing this land this
section and driving all the Christians
out they've just driven out 120,000
Christians that is first and foremost
ethnic cleansing but they were also we
don't we mustn't ever forget Armenians
were victims of the first ever official
genocide between two between 1915 and
1917 when more than a million Armenians
and uh Greek Orthodox and Syriac ayric
Christians were slaughtered by the Turks
Hitler famously said when he was
beginning his program to persecute the
Jews he said uh who remembers the
Armenians because that genocide is still
not even recognized by various countries
so right now yes in Europe a Christian
Nation is is experiencing that kind of
persecution an amazing connection to you
mentioned the Hitler quote which
is the the genocidal political Powers
just think well people will forget and
we'll move on and who's going to talk
about them if they're gone we hear the
phrase never again and it always happens
again never again Rwanda never again
here and it always happens and there are
inquiries and and chest beating
afterwards but this is why the president
preservation of our Christian Community
especially in the Middle East I advocate
for Christians all over the world for
example as well the mainstream media
doesn't talk about the massive
persecution of Christians in Africa in
Nigeria alone last year more than 5,000
Christians were martyred men women and
children never even touches the
mainstream media
5,000 people in one year in Nigeria but
this is exponential across Africa Isis
Isis we're told has been defeated Isis
is just a name isis's baby isis's cousin
they all exist they're exponentially
growing across the world and this is
Islamic jihadism extreme Islam uh but
not just extreme Islam a lot of this
persecution is at least tacitly
supported by I'm not saying all Muslims
are bad of course not but many many
Muslims I've heard recently reports from
from Israel Palestine in Gaza people
have been saying to the Christians a
very tiny Christian Community in Gaza
but people have been saying to them
you're next we've been hearing this
verbatim from people you're you're next
so uh we we are a struggling minority
Christians people think Christianity is
strong in that part of the world is very
weak that is a little bit I guess how
I've been thinking of the Israel
Palestine conflict is not being an
expert in forget centuries Millennia of
of this particular conflict thought all
right well if AOC and Rashida Talib and
ilhan Omar are on one side of an issue I
guess I'm going to be on the other side
of an issue but you put it very well the
they they come for the Saturday people
before the Sunday people uh it's not as
though Christians had been flourishing
in the Middle East in recent years uh
even even 30 40 years ago I think we
have to pick a side and it's never an
excuse for for atrocities it's never an
excuse for certain things no one says
Israel is perfect by a long shot but at
some point you say are you on the side
of people who Cho babies up and Cho
their heads off which did happen or are
you on the other side at that point
there's no sort of reciprocity there's
no middle ground you have to pick a side
uh but for for the Christians they also
experienced this this is the point
people in Iraq say well we we we know
what's happened dases Isis did this Isis
did this to our own people and are still
doing it of course in Africa just last
year on the Feast of Pentecost in the DI
in a dasis in Africa islamists burst
into the Pentecost Sunday mass and
slaughtered more than shot more than 40
men women and children bloody bloody
mess I saw the bishop spoke shortly
afterwards and the bishop uh curiously
one of the we might call useful idiots
again the president of Ireland President
Michael Higgins who's a rather small
fellow about the size of a hob but
without the intelligence of a Hobbit
president Higgins after this uh atrocity
actually in his letter of
condolence blamed global warming and the
bishop of the dasis whose eyes were
flaming said my people were not killed
because of global warming they were
killed because they were Christians
period right if we don't care about that
in the west especially we claim the name
of Christian then there's something
wrong with us right
yeah they're not killed by the sun
monster for one and they're not killed
by the broader impersonal forces that
way you know they're killed by racism or
intolerance or global warming or
something no it's quite personal
actually and and ideas have consequences
and ideas are enacted in time and space
and uh we've got to confront that
reality I I I love your point when you
say we have to pick aside because uh our
Lord is rather clear about being
lukewarm well and also another great
friend of personal friend of ours both a
priest friend we we both know once said
famously uh when you're about to have
your head cut off you don't worry too
much about global warming or air
conditioning uh which I think is an
appetite but yes we have to pick a side
and for a Christian uh if you're worthy
of your name and you don't care about
your brethren suffering in any part of
the world you you probably shouldn't use
the name Christian but then the question
comes well what can we do there's a lot
we can do a great deal praying which is
not the last resort the first Resort uh
Aid and dealing with our legislators we
have to pressurize our legislators trade
trade is a perfect weapon you stop
giving Aid to countries that persecute
persecute anyone persecute the weager
Muslims or we' got China we know all
about that Aid is trade and Aid is very
powerful but it's hardly ever used
another great way to help is to go to
nazaran .org n a s a a n.org father key
thank you for the heroic and excellent
work that you do thank you for sitting
down thank you
Michael